in this video we'll be explaining all
the radioactive eight-legged creatures
that gave Spider-Man his powers so here
are 10 different radioactive spiders as
seen in the Spider-Man movies and
television series up first we have the
remiverse spider also known as the
Columbia University super spider as seen
and Sam raimi's Spider-Man 1 in 2002.
this was one of 15 genetically designed
spiders on display during Peter Parker's
School field trip that bit his hand its
genome is comprised of three different
spiders genetic information with amazing
abilities including super jumping
abilities High tensile organic web and
high-speed nerve conduction or Spider
Sense he also received increased muscle
mass and the proportionate strength of a
spider he awoke with perfect vision no
longer needing his glasses and got
organic web producing spinnerets on his
wrists lastly his hands and fingers
could cling to walls allowing him to
scale tall buildings Sam raimi's story
is similar to the classic Spider-Man
from the comics in which a spider was
accidentally irradiated from above
during a public science exhibition
before biting Peter Parker on the hand
up next is the web verse spider also
known as the Oscorp Industries genetic
modified spider as seen in Mark Webb's
The Amazing Spider-Man in 2012 this
species of spider's scientific name was
arenius oscorpius as it was developed by
Dr Richard Parker Peter's dad and Dr
Kirk Connors the lizard while they
worked on cross species genetics at
Oscorp Industries these spiders are the
result of Peter's father merging his own
DNA into the spiders so the transfer of
powers would only be possible toward his
own children fate would have it that
years later Peter would Snoop into
Oscorp and accidentally come into
contact with the spiders allowing one of
them to bite him Oscorp had been using
the spiders for a different purpose
though the production of industrial bio
cables from the spider's webs the spider
bite gave him abilities similar to Toby
Maguire's version but without any
self-produced organic webs so he had to
create his own web shooters using the
bio cable webs from the same Oscorp
spider species that bit him this version
of the spider is most similar to the
Ultimate Spider-Man from the comics
where the spider was an Oscorp product
as well next up is the mysterious
radioactive spider from the MCU while we
haven't seen the origins of Tom
Holland's Spider-Man abilities we do
know that they came from a spider bite
we also know that it didn't come from
Oscorp as the company doesn't exist in
the MCU but it could have potentially
come from another multi-billion dollar
tech company Stark Industries in Captain
America Civil War Tony Stark is already
aware of Peter Parker and his special
abilities before calling on him to help
in the battle against Captain America so
he could have known about a certain
radioactive spider project that went
wrong and caused a high schooler from
Queens to gain special abilities the
upcoming series Spider-Man freshman year
could give us some additional answers as
to the origins of Peter's abilities in
the MCU his powers from the spider bite
are similar to The previously shown
Spider-Man but he also has no organic
webs so he produced his own Shooters and
web fluid next up we have the 70
Spider-Man in this version we see a
radioactive spider from Peter Parker's
lab back in 1977 CBS aired The Amazing
Spider-Man a made-for-tv movie that
served as the pilot for a short-lived TV
series starring Nicholas Hammond as the
Iconic web Slinger in this case Peter
himself created The Spider and it was a
radiated accidentally during Peter's lab
experiments in college which caused it
to Glow just like in the original Comics
he then made his own web shooters and
fluid to complement his new new spider
powers which were similar to the other
Spider-Man including its signature
Spider Sense up next is the Japanese
Spider-Man who was bitten by Gaia the
Alien Spider in Japan Spider-Man
received a unique adaptation that put a
fresh spin on the character and won over
many fans but this spider is actually a
humanoid Alien named Gaia the bite came
from a spider bracelet that contains a
needle which injected a spider extract
into takuya's blood giving him spider
powers and healing him from the Mortal
wounds he was suffering from having
completed his task Gaia transformed into
a spider that continued to guide
Spider-Man as his mentor although he
shared many of the same abilities as the
other Spider-Man takuya's version of the
spider sense is his telepathic
connection with his spider Mentor acting
like an inner voice that guides him next
up we have the spider that bit Miles
Morales otherwise known as the alchemex
radioactive spider as seen in Spider-Man
into the spider-verse in 2018 this was a
spider labeled number 42 from the
company alchemax this spider bit him in
the sewer as he was making some graffiti
art and it's based on oscorp's number 42
spider from the Ultimate Comics this
spider breed had camouflage and
bioelectric abilities so Milo's received
additional Powers including invisibility
and an electric Venom Blast for number
789 and 10 will show the other four
spider bite events from the animated
spider-verse movie spider-gwen is based
on Earth 65 in the comics where Gwen
Stacy was bit by the spider instead of
Peter Parker at a young age Gwyn was
bitten by a radioactive spider and using
her Newfound spider-like abilities to
fight crime became known as Spider-Woman
Gwen later joined a band as its drummer
and formed a fast friendship with Peter
Parker before losing him the spider bite
also gave her the same Powers as all the
other Spider-Man up next is spider Noir
based on Earth 90214 in the comics which
was characterized with more mystical
elements in this version Peter broke an
antique spider Idol that released a
horde of spiders and one of them bit him
then a spider God visited him in his
dream granting him Powers this version
of Spider-Man is a dark and
monochromatic version of Peter Parker
and he decided to use his abilities to
end the violence and the Injustice of
his City by becoming the Vigilante known
as Spider-Man he would also find time to
work as a private eye on the side next
up is Penny Parker based on Earth 14512
in the comics in which a radioactive
spider bit Penny Parker creating a
telepathic link between Penny and the
spider robot suits computer allowing her
to Pilot it penny is extremely
intelligent like most of the other
versions of Peter Parker but she sets
herself apart by having great abilities
in terms of technical skill next we have
spider ham based on Earth 8311 in the
comics where Peter was originally a
spider and was actually bit by a
radioactive Pig this transformed him
into an anthropomorphic Pig with spider
powers Peter spent his days as a
photographer for the daily Beagle And as
the crime-fighting spider ham aside from
the classic Powers he shares with most
of the other spider people due to the
nature of his tuned Universe Spider-Man
is nearly invulnerable and extremely
agile he's capable of Feats that normal
people can't achieve such as carrying an
infinite amount of items such as hammers
magnets and anvils in his pockets lastly
we have the honorable mention of
Spider-Man 2099 otherwise known as
Miguel O'Hara in this version Miguel's
jeans were spliced with a spider's DNA
giving him spider abilities including
fangs and Talons Miguel O'Hara is a
spider person from Earth 928 a universe
set in the future and he lives in Nueva
York featured in the film Spider-Man
across the spider-verse Subscribe for
more Marvel content and if you liked the
video check out the one on your screen
too